[Music]
with the return to school just days away
many are wondering how they'll be able
to stay open in the week to the 27th of
december an estimated one in 20
secondary pupils in england that's those
aged over 11 had coronavirus
the rise in cases is driven by the more
transmissible omicron variant now
secondary pupils in england will have to
wear a face covering at least for the
next three weeks and the education
watchdog offset says there'll be no
inspections in the first week of term
was two-thirds of adults have been
boosted uh obviously children have not
so that's why we've brought in some
additional measures within schools we're
making available things like ventilators
and extra 7000
ventilation units for those classrooms
where it's difficult
to ventilate that's largely backed by
school leaders the biggest threat to
education it seems to me is not having
those members of staff to teach young
people and if the way we try and keep
our schools more reassuringly safe is
through face coverings is through
changes to ofsted is through improved
ventilation then that will be definitely
a price worth paying hi uk
take a seat for me please thank you the
government's clearly worried about staff
absences due to covert
it's asked bosses in the public sector
to plan for up to a quarter of the
workforce being off it's relied heavily
on an extensive program of boosters or
third vaccination doses to drive down
coronavirus rates but that's being
outpaced by omicron
and one of the key tools for keeping the
economy going regular testing isn't
working properly there have been severe
shortages of all types of tests
including the rapid lateral flow tests
problems in accessing covid19 tests are
increasing concerns in important sectors
such as the health service the main
doctors union here says its members are
having trouble getting tests which means
they're worried that they're infecting
their patients
the uk government insists more
restrictions must be a last resort but
with hospitals warning covets placing
immense pressures on them experts say
the only alternative is changes in
behavior be fully immunized take your
boosters and
wear a good quality mask and ffp2 mask
and avoid those indoor closed poorly
ventilated places if we were to exercise
all of those measures ourselves we by
our own efforts would bring down the
case numbers
for now the only certainty is that
omicron's having an impact on workplaces
around the country what isn't known is
how well the measures in place will deal
with it nadeem baba al jazeera london